l'une est ce que vous avez un doute sur
quelqu'un d'absolument et un gros dos si
je se dire chaque fois à bâle concert de
jean michel maire alors satisfait alors
c'est quoi c'est un très très gros dos
jean-mi m'a confié andy terre en été en
loge j'allume a confié s'être fait
retirer un peu de graisse de son popotin
pour avoir un l'insérer dans son engin
pour qu'il soit un peu mais comme vous
tu as aimé
[Rires]
j'ai écouté mon père si ça avait été
vrai j'aurais été carrément hors norme
mais c'est complètement mythomane et dit
que c'est faux non c'est pas ce que vous
avez à 12 sur quelques années ils ont
mis ce que vous avez à dos sur keita en
vrai jean michel mercier fait grossir le
5 mai faudra vraiment ce mois là
évidemment pendant vue l'organe scène
vous concernera jamais mais pour les
gens qui veulent le faire vous faire
attention parce que ça ne dure que six
mois à lui les fennecs moi non et oui
parce que c'est ma vraie grèce qu'on a
appris moi c'est pas l'assise et laurine
la grèce que vous mais elles font donc
ça coûte 3500 euros au bout de 6 à 8
mois et sature joli nom et ses jolies
vimont donc il faut se balader le cisi à
lèvres dans ce qu on montre à tout le
monde c'est vraiment amusant qu'un dos
faut pas attendre d'accord très bien
merci
est-ce que vous avez raison sur quelques
gens me traitent était en train de
choquer la non daniel non et c'est vrai
nom jean loup jours c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai la peene plastie ça coûte
3500 euros
alors voilà c'est c'est très bien fait
c'est une petite canule dans la vraie
paix non parce qu'ils n'ont pas c'est
parce que son parti